the brexit talks between labour and the
government are expected to continue
tomorrow
in an attempt to try and break the
impasse and joining us now is the shadow
attorney general baroness shami
chakarbati thank you very much for being
on the programme this morning now very
keen to talk to you about brexit but i
did just want to start with the
allegations that are in the sunday times
about the way that labour is dealing
with complaints of anti-semitism within
the party
um according to the sunday times labour
members investigating
investigated for posting harl hitler
dues the problem
haven't been expelled even though the
complaints were received a year ago
and jeremy corwin's office involved in
approving delaying or blocking
at least 101 complaints of anti-semitism
i mean it's nearly three years since
your report
what's your reaction to this well i have
to say i you can imagine that i checked
this out before coming on because i
fully expected to
you know to to have to talk about this
um
the part those people in the party who
have looked at the specific allegations
in the sunday times refute then
and they actually challenged the
accuracy of the reporting some of the
emails that have been leaked
actually demonstrate the opposite of
what is being spun in the sunday times
that's what my colleagues tell me that
particular lines are extracted from
emails
to actually give the opposite impression
of what was the fact
so that often some of these emails are
about actually disciplining people
and they're quoted out of context to
make it look like the reverse but but
there is a serious issue
here um we have had a problem in the
labour party and by the way it goes
way back i um i looked at a very
unsavory
general election poster whilst i was um
waiting to come on from 2005
presenting michael howard in a in a very
unattractive way
that i think can only be described as an
anti-semitic trope that was 2005.
let's be honest we've had problems as as
there are in all parties not just on
anti-semitism but other forms of racism
too
we sort of heard that from sam jima a
few minutes ago
we have to not be partisan about
tackling racism we have to not be
factional
there was a period between general
secretaries when um
and then some junior staff who were
dealing with complaints
looked to the leader's office for for
leadership
and advice and support but that practice
ended
when jenny formby uh took over
that's a big deal for a lot of people
isn't it like an interesting example
so just to be clear on that because i
have quizzed people about this
because i've got a personal investment
in this as you know as well as coming on
to your to your show there was a hiatus
between general secretaries
when junior staff who were dealing with
complaints um
asked for leadership and guidance they
had the final decision any of that's
still going on
i am told unequivocally no because
because jenny formby is a very strong
general secretary who is committed to
making this
a priority so there is no interference
from jeremy corbyn
or his staff in the disciplinary process
now does that mean
that we're yet where we want to be no of
course not because
one one example of bad behavior is one
too many but we've been trying to
improve our processes
speed them up at the same time you have
to speed them up and still be robust and
fair
so there's more to do but um but there
is no
interference from jeremy or his staff
that under the new general secretary
we've we've got a a more correct process
i mean you are
one of the uk's leading human rights
advocates
aren't you really angry about this i am
very angry but but
but i returned to this point whether
it's islamophobia in the conservative
party or other forms of racism as in sam
jima's case we're talking about whether
or not no
no no no absolutely i don't believe
that you can tackle racism in any party
or in society if you make it a party
political or faction or internal
factional
matter i think we have to just say that
this is too
important to politicize or factionalize
we have
problems we have had problems for some
time
in the labour party and there's a
particular manifestation
of anti-semitism that you sometimes get
on the left
which is to confuse it with anti-elitism
say tropes about bankers and can
you know that's a particular danger and
trap that
that is there on the left we have to
tackle it
but it will be much easier to tackle it
if we don't make it
um a personal attack on jeremy corbyn
or a or a conservative attack on labor
or
or an inter-factional attack it seems to
me and we we need to take the same
approach by the way
when there are claims about the
conservative party not go oh the tories
have got a problem with islamophobia now
we've got to come together as democratic
people
in a context of the rise of the far
right
in europe and in this country the
democratic people who are anti-racist
need to come together
and tackle it in that way i mean later
today the jewish labour
movement are going to be voting on
whether they have confidence in jeremy
corbyn's leadership so my plea to my
plea to then
is is not to personalize it
because as i say that post feel that
it's okay
look of course i understand that and
he's the leader of the party and that's
what they would say
that how do how can we how can we take
on our party
without a vote of confidence in the
leader my plea
to the jewish labor movement is to stay
in the labour movement
and to tackle racism together not
to personalize it and make it about
jeremy corbyn because he is one person
and he won't be leader
forever we have to make this
non-factional
non-personal and and work together and
that's that's my plea
to the colleagues and comrades in the
jewish labour movement who
are such an important part of labour's
history and labour's story
okay um now i'm keen to move on to
brexit and jeremy corbyn and theresa may
have been
having talks last week we've got more
talks planned for tomorrow
are you optimistic that there's the deal
to be struck
i'm not i'm one of life's optimists so
you know i always try to be
uh optimistic but i did speak um to
people who've been
in the room i spoke in particular uh
last night to rebecca long bailey
our shadow business secretary and so far
um our
impression is that mrs may has not moved
an
inch on her red lines that is worrying
to me
because the clock is running down we're
sort of
almost beyond midnight because you know
with past the 29th
of march um she's asking for more time
but but you have to compromise and
compromise is not just telling us again
and again how good your existing deal is
that you know this is a deal that's been
voted down in parliament
three times and my understanding is that
whilst people have been
mutually respectful in these discussions
um you know they've been they've been
respectful and friendly and positive in
tone
in substance as yet there's been not
a jot of movement from the government
and that just
that isn't going to break the deadlock
i'm afraid i'm interested to know if
there's been any compromise on labour's
uh side as well uh particularly with
regards to a second referendum because
we've been hearing slightly different
things from
the shadow cabinet we can have a quick
look just to illustrate to our viewers i
thought you might do that
exactly and just to make it clear we've
got uh emily thornbury the shadow
foreign secretary saying any deal agreed
by parliament
must be subject to a confirmatory public
vote and rebecca long bailey on the
other side
if we get exactly what we want a good
strong deal then i would struggle to
find a reason to put that to a public
vote um i mean you can see why people
are confused is it a red line or
what is the position so you um know that
as of our party conference last autumn
um a second referendum became part of
our policy but as sam gina said it's a
process point it's not an end in itself
and the purpose of having a second
referendum would be
to stop a catastrophic no deal that we
cannot countenance for the reasons that
that just phillips said in in that
fantastic interview by the way it was a
wonderful piece of political tv
we cannot have a no deal because it
would be devastating to the lives
of so many people in britain to business
to the trade unions
but in particular to the poor so to stop
a no deal to stop a bad deal and
crucially to break a parliamentary
deadlock
i have to more and more agree with sam
and with jess that we can't go on like
this if we can't get
proper proper real consensus in
parliament it seems to me
that a public vote that includes a
general election or a second referendum
become more and more likely even
necessary but it's not a red line
if just listening to you if jeremy
corbyn and theresa may do manage to get
a deal that they can both agree on
that wouldn't necessarily have to be put
to a public focus well i'm i'm
personally cautious about you know
putting shammy's red lines out when
shammy's not in the room and we're
saying we're in the compromise business
but i'm telling you what i think is
likely i don't see
at this point in this process after
nearly three years since the referendum
with no um no agreement in the
conservative policy
with um yes we some of the options that
are closer to our preference like a
customs union
um got the most support in parliament
but that still was not
overwhelming support i i find it almost
impossible to
to imagine that theresa may and jeremy
corbyn can go and have a cup of tea in a
room
or several cups of tea over several days
and then come out
and the smoke goes up and everyone's
going to be happy so it seems to me this
has been left
so late in the day and i'm afraid i must
criticize mrs may a bit for that
it's been left so late in the day it's
hard to imagine
that we're going to make real progress
now without either a general election
or as or a second referendum on any deal
that she can get over the line in
parliament and it has to be
got over the line in parliament this is
not going to be a bilateral
a bilateral deal between the leaders of
the
of the two main parties they need to be
talking about what might get through the
house of commons i mean talking about
areas of agreement the prime minister
said this morning that the fact is on
brexit there are
areas where the two main parties agree
the first example she gives
is we both want to end free movement do
you share the same policy on immigration
free movement well clearly i mean she
and her party are a much more
anti-immigration party and labor's never
been an anti-immigration party there
have been times in the past when i
haven't liked some of the labour party's
rhetoric let's be clear
on immigration i don't think that helped
when those same people
were were so uh campaigning for remain
um in the referendum however um we are
where we are at our in our manifesto
in 2017 we said when you leave the eu
the concept of free movement ends but
that doesn't mean movement ends
so i do think that we are much more
positive about
the rights of eu nationals in the uk and
indeed of brits in
europe and and movement between the two